Oh, election day. The day Americans cast their votes everywhere on who will be their next president.
Except, they don't really do that.
So, what really happens on election day? It's a little complicated because of something
It's called "the Electoral College" (Electoral College).
To make it a little simple, think of the Electoral College as a collection of the 538
votes that decide who the president will be.
Why 538?
Because it is the number of senators (100) plus the number of representatives (438) in
Kongresset. Why are there 438 representatives in Congress?
Stop asking so many questions we try to keep it simple:
These 538 votes in the electoral college are not given directly to the citizens, but instead
shared between the Länder.
So how do the electoral college delegate the votes?
Each state, regardless of population, gets 3 votes to begin with. The remaining votes
be fed in proportion to the population of the state. The more people
The state has, the more votes it gets.
Here is a map of the USA that shows how much voting power they have by doing
a hexagon equal to a vote in the electoral college.
Because the voices are mostly - albeit not always - proprietary to the crowd, is
It also includes a map of where people live, with a small bonus for the smaller states to make them
a bit bigger than they would otherwise be.
In early November, when the citizens go to the polling stations, they do not vote directly on the president,
in fact, they show their state how they think the state should use its votes in the electoral college.
48 out of 50 states give all their votes to the candidate who wins
majority in their state.
Take Florida, which has 29 votes in the Electoral College. If a candidate wins majority,
No matter how narrow the majority is, he gets all the votes.
Then the road to the White House is simple: wind majority in enough states to get
more than half the votes in the electoral college and then you are allowed to sit at "the Big Desk".
It wasn't so complicated you say so.
But some details are still missing:
The Electoral College loves states, but what about the 11 million Americans who do not live
in a state?
What happens to their voice and where do they really hide?
There live approx. 600,000 in Columbia districts, which is a site specifically set aside for * not *
to be a state so that the main state would be free of local politics.
For most of American history, people living in DC were not allowed to vote
in the presidential election. Until 1964, when the Constitution was changed to give the district the same number
votes as the least populated state, Wyoming.
So the Electoral College likes DC But do you know who it doesn't like? Territories.
They often forgot Puerto Rico, Guam, the US Virgin Islands and the Northern Mariana Islands
get no votes from the electoral college as they are not states and do not have any particular
constitutional change that recognizes them.
Which is a little strange since they are part of the United States and everyone who lives in the United States
are US citizens, so - in most cases - they are exactly like DC
4.4 million people live in the territories - it may not sound like much, but it's more
than in Wyoming, Vermont, North Dakota, South Dakota, Alaska and Delaware.
Together.
But still, they get no votes in the electoral college.
The whole situation with the territories is extraordinary when considering the last group
by Americans who do not live in the states - the 6.3 million Americans living abroad.
If you are a US citizen who moves to another country, you can as a rule send
your vote by post to the last state you lived in.
But if you move * within the United States * to one of its territories, you lose the court
to vote for the presidential election as long as you live there - making these areas the only areas
on the whole globe where Americans cannot vote for the presidential election.
In fact, the only areas in the entire universe when American astronauts are allowed
to vote from the room.
The last complicated part of the electoral college is the strangest and has to do with the voices
in itself.
In fact, the state of Florida - and all the other states - does not give the votes of a candidate
it's just a simplified way to explain it because in reality the situation is ...
curios.
What the citizens vote for on election day is a group of electorate appointed by the political
parties that elect the president on behalf of the citizens.
The number of votes a state receives from the Election College is actually that number
electorate the state must send to the college meeting to vote for who the president
becomes.
What makes it strange is that while these constituents promise they will vote for
The desire of the citizens is actually mandatory.
Electors are actually free to vote as they please. While this has never swung a choice,
It has happened 87 times before voters voted against the wishes of the people who have chosen
them.
Why have you seen this crazy system where a small number of people who are basically totally unknown
the civilian population, really choose who the president should be?
Because in the 1700s - when the Election College was conceived - was the quickest way to
Providing information to write it on a piece of paper, give it to a guy on one
horse, wish him "godspeed, good sir" (good luck) and hope that he was not killed by Indians or died of
dysentery on the road.
Because information was moving so slowly and landing was so great, the idea was
to send all the constituents to Washington where they could have the most current information
to make the decisions for the people at home who did not know the latest news.
Today, where we send information with light rays in fiber optic wires instead
on the back of herd animals, this aspect of the electoral college might seem
a bit old fashioned.
Nevertheless, while most believe that the presidential election will take place in early November,
Don't do it - it's the choice that decides who the constituents will be.
The 538 electors who are elected then meet in early December and cast the right votes
who decides who is the next president of the United States.